merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues qu'il est
compliqué de simplifier
réclamé par notre collègue Olivier Cadic
depuis un rapport d'avril 2018 de la
délégation aux entreprises la fusion des
1400 guichets des six pôles de
formalités aux entreprises a été réalisé
par la loi Pâques du 22 mai 2019 le
choix de l'INPI pour gérer ce guichet
unique avait surpris on ne passe pas
facilement de l'enregistrement de 15000
brevets par an à la gestion de 5
millions de formalités concernant les
créations d'entreprises les
modifications et les cessations on
simplifie pas au numérisant sans alléger
les procédures sur l'année 2022 les
créateurs et entrepreneurs ont pu
utiliser ce service marqué par de
nombreux dysfonctionnements et blocages
depuis le 1er janvier 2023 le site et la
voie unique obligatoire pour effectuer
les différentes formalités d'entreprise
malheureusement une attaque informatique
l'a rendu inutilisable du 3 au 7 janvier
monsieur le ministre unique
fonctionnera-t-il correctement et
surtout quand sera-t-il simplifié pour
que nos entrepreneurs produisent plutôt
de la valeur que des renseignements
administratifs
[Applaudissements]